i was someone who kind of considered  myself a fake christian a little bit i  was saying that i was kind of religious  but wasn't really doing anything so when  covet hit i was home alone i decided to  order the quran and then order the bible  to read both and so i ended up reading  the bible and i read the four gospels  and it's really like with anything that  when you get any sort of type of  information presented to you and you  either have to make a choice you either  ignore the information you accept it as  truth or you think that it's false and  so what i did after i read it i said  okay i think that this is true and i'm  going to to change my life because of it  and i decided to to get baptized one of  the greatest decisions i ever made was  to do that you know your life gets  harder but it's well worth it